well joe kelly will be the opener for
the dodgers in what is a bullpen game
well he made six appearances already in
the postseason this is his first start
as an opener freddie freeman coming
alive here
in the two games in los angeles he was
over eight to start this lcs with seven
strikeouts
and in the air right center that ball is
tattooed and freddie freeman a two-run
blast
it had the sound
and freeman puts the braves on the board
in the first inning
freddie freeman with his third home run
of the postseason
a no doubter to right center field
and a two-run shot in the braves play
long ball once again here in game five
adam duvall another one started the post
season oh for seven since eight for 21
with a homer and four rbis joe kelly's
28th pitch of the first inning one ball
two strikes adam duvall
it's outside and it's two and two
dave roberts going out along with possum
the trainer and kelly's coming out of
the game
medical report from the dodger clubhouse
joe kelly comes out of the game right
bicep tightness
phillips has been in one game that was
in game three
right-hander deals and duvall strikes
out swinging and that ends the inning
max freed the 27 year old left-hander
out of harvard west lake high school in
studio city he was 14-7 during the
regular season seeger climbing in left
on left matchup
2-2 on the way
got him looking strike three
a perfect fastball seeger was a statue
in the left-hand batter's box
pollock 231 of the postseason yo-1
there's a shot to left
well hit on its way and pollock has hit
it out
aj pollock's first home run of the post
season the dodgers are on the board it
is two to one during the regular year he
hit 21.
and now here's fools
and the 3-2 and he whistles one into the
left
albert pujols he got the slider and he
did not miss
chris taylor coming up free delivers
and that one is hammered to left and
it's on its way and it has gone a home
run
just like that the dodgers have a three
to two lead
home run pollock single pujo
two-run home run for taylor
that'll bring steven souza jr up to the
plate he'll be pinch hitting for the
pitcher spot free to the belt pitch on
the way swung on miss strike three
dodgers three braves two bottom of the
second seeger the eighth dodger to the
plate here in the second inning 2-0 on
the way ground ball right side freddie
backhands underhand toss long toss max
is there and he gets the out and here's
pujols
oh two pits
dumps one into right center
pollock will turn and head to third the
throw comes in it is late palace
now chris taylor who homered in his
first at-bat
dodgers already have seven hits
first and third one out and taylor
little flair these on the run can't get
it base hit in the score pollock
chris taylor drives in his third run of
the game
4-2 dodgers in the third
it'll be bellinger coming to the plate
and here it is for max
got him swinging strike three
threw a fastball by him 97. andy byrne
spent most of his year at oklahoma city
right-handed batter
first a b of the postseason
he it's a chopper up the middle taken by
ozzy
a long throw to first base and that is
in time for the out wow what a play by
ozzie uh for sure he's about to go to
second base but a long throw from back
of second all the way over to first and
they get the out see if duval can see
more than one pitch
set and delivers duvall strikes out
swinging on a slider no runs no hits no
errors and nobody left
first pitch swinger and corey seeger
seeger has hit seven
career homers in the postseason against
atlanta it's the most home runs ever hit
against the braves in the postseason
hits that one sharply always is right
there nice down at it and he makes the
play to win the inning
left-handed hitting peterson fly to
center in his first at-bat
the o2 swung on and missed strike three
four up four down for grouder all two
strikeouts in a row that'll bring up
travis darno
max freed on deck
and there's a liner to the left
in and over to make the catches pollock
another one two three inning for bruce
star granderol
though runzo hits though heiress nobody
left
after four and a half it's the dodgers
four
and the braves two so chris martin will
face chris taylor 4-2 dodger lead taylor
in the air to center field and balls on
the barrel that ball is deep and she
is chris taylor a two-run home run
six to two dodgers
and game five
is chris taylor's game
and now gradder all will bat for himself
one-two pitch on the way swinging to
miss strike three so he fans him that
ends the bottom of the fifth inning but
two more runs for the dodgers
freddie freeman coming up
dodger six
atlanta two
full count pitch to freeman
and a fly ball to left
right at aj pollock he's there and he's
got it
no runs and one hit one man left
we'll go to the bottom half of the six
with the dodgers leading in
and choc peterson coming up jack
peterson with two out and nobody on
crime and delivers and peterson grounds
it into short right field trey turner on
the ship picks it up throws peterson out
one two three four creighton no runs no
hits though airs nobody left seventh
inning stretch
in game five of the national league
championship series it's the dodgers six
and the braves too
and here comes chris taylor what a night
tonight
two-two oh
that's deep left center chris taylor
not one not two but three
class taylor
the knight of his life
[Applause]
seven to two dodgers
[Applause]
home run number three for taylor
six rbis
craig turner two for three and has been
hit by a pitch tonight
that's in scoring position now nobody
out he takes off the third in a basement
that's hit the deck now he's on his feet
he'll score
and it's an rbi single
trey turner with his third hit of the
game
now here's pollock two for four
and a fly ball to left center field and
that baby is long gone
pollock with two home runs
and the dodgers now lead it
11 11-2
the route is on
what a night the dodgers are back from
the dead now it's pujols
pitch to pools ground ball into the hole
ozzy a lungs deep in the hole gloves it
fires over what a play a one-off throw
over to freddie freeman and that gets
albert fools on the doorstep of history
right here chris taylor will walk to the
plate
with three home runs
2-2 pitch and down he goes a
strikeout austin reilly with two out
he's over for three tonight a ball and
two strikes kenley chance
to riley and the pitch
fly ball right field bets going back on
the warning track he's got it the
dodgers win 11-2
mykolo vulture organic seltzer as real
as it tastes